police in the u.k are saying they've
arrested two teenagers in connection
with the hostage situation at a texas
synagogue over the weekend it is unclear
if they are facing charges at the time
officials say that 44-year-old malik
faisal akram a british citizen was
responsible for the standoff a standoff
that president joe biden has called an
act of terror omar villafranca is
following the investigation and we find
him in colleyville texas for us omar
good morning
good morning we know the suspect came to
the u.s about two weeks ago through new
york's jfk airport what we don't know is
how he got a gun once he got here
sources are telling cbs news that akram
was able to get into the synagogue
behind me by claiming he was homeless
and that's when he pulled a gun
for nearly 11 hours on saturday law
enforcement stood ready outside of
congregation beth israel inside four
hostages were held at gunpoint their
saturday services interrupted by malik
faisal akram whose shouting could be
heard on the service's live stream
stacy silverman is a member of the
congregation she says she watched the
live stream until it was cut off we
couldn't see him
only here because the camera was focused
on one of the prayers since we couldn't
see him we thought you know we just we
were terrified that he'd start shooting
officials say 44 year old akram asked
negotiators for the release of afia
siddiqui who is currently in federal
prison in texas for the attempted murder
of u.s forces in afghanistan she's
suspected of having ties to al-qaeda and
has even been called lady al-qaeda in a
statement siddiqui's legal counsel said
we want the assailant to know that his
actions are wicked and directly
undermine those of us who are seeking
justice for dr affia shortly after 5 pm
akram released one of the hostages
after four more hours of negotiations
the fbi's elite hostage rescue team
flown in from their base in quantico
virginia moved in after a loud bang and
the sound of gunshots akram was dead and
all four hostages were safe i'm also
extremely proud of the team of
negotiators fbi agents and local police
officers
who worked all day long and it's very
likely this situation would have ended
very badly early on in the day had we
not had professional consistent
negotiation with the subject
the rabbi said in the last hour of the
standoff that akron was getting
increasingly belligerent and the rabbis
said that he and the other hostages were
able to escape due in part to the fact
that they had been going through active
shooter and security training over the
last several years and the numbers
showed that that training is needed 2020
had the third highest rate of
anti-semitic incidents since the adl
started recording them in 1979.
tony just just an amazing data point
there an amazing work by law enforcement
omar thank you